produire de l'énergie renouvelable pour
contribuer à l'autonomie électrique en
2030 en valorisant le patrimoine bâti du
département de la réunion met à
disposition des toitures de 23 collèges
à des solaristes pour l'installation de
panneaux photovoltaïques
il ya des conventions d'occupation du
domaine public présence d'afficheurs
pédagogique indiquant la production
d'électricité et le gain co2 pour la
sensibilisation des collégiens
réalisation et exploitation d'une
microcentrale hydroélectrique de 200
kilowatts au niveau du réservoir rt4 de
l'antenne 4 du projet irrigation
littoral ouest permettant le turbinage
de l'eau provenant du réservoir de tête
de mon repos et assurant une
alimentation de l'antenne d'irrigation
de long qui arrive de mon repos sur
saint-paul et qui est directement
turbiner dans le réservoir
de l'antenne quatre transit à peu près
chaque année 4 à 6 millions de mètres
cubes qui sont sur biner et cette eau
permet l'irrigation en fait pour les
agriculteurs sur le territoire ouest de
la rue suite à appel à projets une
convention a été signée pour une durée
de 20 ans opération subventionnée par le
feder et la région réunion